top military leaders are attacking a
conservative journalist for suggesting
that pregnant women maybe don't make the
best
soldiers very very modest sort of claim
here
listening to pc diatribes from the
pentagon
is pathetic it is dispiriting but it is
teaching right-wingers an important
lesson
when even the military goes woke
conservatives have
no institutional power left military was
sort of the last one where we thought oh
that's
kind of a conservative institution well
so much for that maybe it's time to
start winning
and wielding actual political power
just an idea i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from michael
mckay who says 115 days to slow the
spread
and then maybe joe biden will give a
press conference
maybe or then maybe it'll just get
extended a little while longer
it's pretty clear that at least
one of the motivations for continuing to
drag this out two weeks two months
now some people saying two years is
because
these eggheads and these politicians
want to keep their power and they don't
want any accountability a lot of these
emergency powers are saying look in the
ordinary operation of government we
wouldn't be able to do this tell you to
do this but
we have certain police powers because of
a pandemic and that is now being dragged
out
indefinitely not so great
you're going to want to protect yourself
from having people take away
your rights you're going to want to
protect yourself from having people take
away your data which is why you got to
turn to
expressvpn i love expressvpn i was using
it just
last night big tech companies have a ton
of power
in our country and as private entities
they can operate pretty much as they
choose
protect your personal data from bigtech
with the vpn that i trust for my online
protection
expressvpn when i use expressvpn my
connection gets
rerouted through their secure encrypted
servers so that these companies cannot
see my ip address at all my internet
activity becomes anonymized
my network data is encrypted i recommend
expressvpn to anyone who uses the
internet which is
i think statistically everyone the best
part is you don't need to be tech savvy
at all to use expressvpn i certainly am
not
just download the app on your phone or
your computer tap one button you're
protected
protect your internet activity with the
vpn that i use every single day i used
to think
who cares no one's after my data i think
that the last couple of years should
have shown us that that is simply not
the case visit expressvpn.com
michael to get three extra months free
on a one-year package that is
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael to get three extra months for
free that is expressvpn.com
michael i never go online now without
expressvpn
and i strongly encourage you to go check
out expressvpn as well
the command senior enlisted leader of
the
u.s space command so this is obviously
the new branch of the military was
announced
under president trump but this guy's a
28-year military veteran
scott stalker he got very upset
because tucker carlson said that
pregnant
women are not the most lethal
people on the planet i understand some
comments were made yesterday and i
watched the clip
that mr carlson produced as he referred
to pregnant women in the military
i'll remind everyone that his opinion
which he has a right to
is based off of actually zero days of
service in the armed forces
let me offer you my opinion my opinion
is based off of 28 years of actual
service in the military
28 years in the marine corps in combat
operations out at sea
and in garrison and so he was talking
specifically
about pregnant women in the armed forces
today and how it makes us
less less lethal and less fit and less
ready let me tell you where he's wrong
those decisions were made by medical
professionals by commanders
and our civilian leadership that allows
for women to have more time with their
children
to recuperate to get fit and ready
to take that time that's necessary that
our medical professionals know is needed
which match actually makes us a more
lethal and ready and fit force
let's remember that those opinions were
made by an individual
who has never served a day in his life
28 years experience this guy has
he's got an impressive credential he's
got this blue check mark on twitter
which is reflective of his position as a
senior enlisted leader
and not one iota of common sense
not one little bit
the decision to have women in the
military the decision more recent
decision of women in combat roles
that was a political decision that was
not a tactical decision
i understand the political arguments for
it the political arguments were that
if we're going to have true equality for
women if we're not going to have
women underneath the patriarchy then
they need to be able to do all the
wonderful privileges that
and get all the wonderful privileges
that men have including
fighting in war and dodging bullets and
and all that sort of thing this is
considered some privilege
and so therefore because of that as a
political matter we need to let women
uh fight and now this is being taken
even to the craziest extreme
which is we need to let pregnant women
fight or something we need we
break we need we need to pretend that
pregnant women are just as fit and
lethal
as men are they do i've learned have a
very lethal
and acerbic uh tongue and wit sometimes
i've learned this through my own
experience with pregnant women but in
terms of physicality
it's just not the case as a tactical
matter
men are bigger faster and physically
stronger
than women and certainly than pregnant
women there's no question about that the
whole reason
that we're even debating the the tran
the trans women
right the men playing in women's sports
issue is because men beat women in
women's sports
because men and women are different and
men are physically stronger
than women now you'll notice here this
guy stalker
he he's coming there he's in his uniform
he says look tucker carlson that guy
never served a day in his life not like
me
so that journalist he has no right you
know sure he can have his opinion
but he's wrong he's never served ever in
his life
uh and i'm gonna debunk his arguments
and then what does he do
he never addresses his argument he just
says women
are in the military and that's good
you're like okay well
yes they are in the military that's
objectively true you think
it's good that pregnant women are
fighting
i don't think that's good i think that's
bad but you and then he sort of said
he's like and they they need to
rest up so they can be physically fit
again you say well that's not what
anybody's even talking about
mr stalker so then there was a little
bit of a backlash
stalker decides he's going to issue a
non-apology apology
wow last 24 hours have been pretty
intense for me ladies and gentlemen
and i just wanted to briefly say thank
you to everyone that uh wrote me
that everyone that called texted sent me
a message on twitter or facebook
i appreciate it and i even appreciate
the fact that those of you had different
opinions
uh posted those as well what i won't do
is engage in a personal attack with mr
carlson or anybody
i don't believe in doing that i think
that my comments stand on themselves
i was making a non-political statement
about my service members and teammates
in the united states armed forces i
don't make political comments
and i certainly don't attack our media i
think they have a right and it's a
necessity of this nation
to have a fair and free press and so mr
carlson and everyone that's reporting
stories
please continue to do so i think it's
important that i just make a comment
that i say my comments are based on 28
years of service
he doesn't have any service that does
not mean his
his points aren't valid and so i think
everyone has a right to their opinion
does not mean his points aren't valid i
mean my whole video
was about how his points aren't valid
and uh
look i'm saying it's not a personal
attack i mean my whole video was
personally attacking
tucker carlson but look it wasn't
political okay even though
my entire video was making political
points notice
how quick that guy took his uniform off
you know that first one he's got the
uniform on he's using it
to make his entire point is basically
that tucker carlson is wrong and we
shouldn't take him seriously anyway
because he's never served in the
military
not like me not like me mr stalker now
all that goes away because of the
backlash
the whole video was claiming that
tucker's points are invalid the military
would seem to disagree though there's a
new report out research
showed that the army combat fitness test
it's the same one for male and female
soldiers
was leading to lower results for women
an early pentagon study this is
according to the telegraph
said that women were failing the acft at
a rate of 65 percent
well only well 90 of men were passing
the a
c f t i'm not saying this to denigrate
women
i'm sure these women are extremely
strong but men and women are different
and men are physically stronger than
women that is why
historically speaking warriors have been
men this is outrage i mean this guy
should obviously lose his leadership
position there's
there is no question about that he
should have his twitter account taken
away from him
by his by his bosses in the military
right by
by the top brass but but also he should
lose his leadership position this is an
incredible abuse of power
and it's also just profoundly stupid
what he's saying
doesn't make any sense and it is so
dispiriting for for supporters of the
military
to to listen to this woke nonsense out
of
out of someone who's in a leadership
position it would be good if this guy
could apologize but he can't apologize
because our culture
has made that almost impossible there's
a story i haven't really covered that
much because
i i personally don't care about it but
at this point it is now
actually telling us something about the
culture the bachelor
you know the bachelor apparently there's
a host of the bachelor named chris
harrison hadn't heard of him until about
a week or two ago
he's not going to be returning to the
show he's been hosting this thing
forever apparently
and there's a controversy because chris
harrison made comments defending
a bachelor contestant who or
bachelorette or something i don't know
who had attended an antebellum south
party
years prior when she was in college here
was his
commentary on it what are your thoughts
about rachel kirknell
and the allegations attached to her a
couple of things first and foremost i
don't know
i haven't talked to rachel about it and
and this is again
where we all need to have a little grace
a little understanding a little
compassion because i've seen some stuff
online
again this judge jury executioner thing
where people are just tearing this
girl's life apart and diving into like
her parents and her parents voting
record and what it's it's
unbelievably alarming to watch this
i haven't heard rachel speak on this yet
and until i actually hear this woman
have a chance to speak
who am i to say any of this you know i
saw a picture of her at a sorority party
five years ago and that's it like boom
like okay well this this girl
is in this book now and she's now in
this group and i'm like
really oh chris oh
poor sweet chris you
you do not know what kind of a situation
you are in politically right now and
unfortunately
he made in not only did he make the
wrong
choice there if he wanted to keep this
mainstream gig to
contradict the pc police but he has
subsequently made
every other wrong decision
very important to note what he actually
did because people are saying it was he
made a racial comment and this and that
a girl who was on the show attended a
party in
college that was about the south the
antebellum south
and so they dressed up like the
antebellum south
so you have to believe that that was
vicious and vile and racist okay people
are debating that
you have to believe then that it matters
that she went to this party years ago
and you have to believe that it is it is
a political crime
for this guy to defend this girl from
having her life destroyed for something
she did years ago by just showing up to
a party
but chris didn't realize that and chris
fell into a huge
pc trap which we'll get to in just one
second but first if you don't want to
fall into any
traps with all the craziness going on
right now might be worth considering
investing in
precious metals the price of gold has
been skyrocketing lately now there is a
new way to buy gold to a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as thirty dollars a
month how is that possible michael
gold costs more than thirty dollars well
it does it's an ingenious way to do it
you pay each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house just recently acre has introduced
a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar acre lets you invest in physical
gold without coming out of pocket all at
once and it keeps you updated
on your gold stash every month and ships
once you reach the price
threshold with acre taking physical
delivery of your gold means it's safe
and sound and in
your hands i have really enjoyed
investing
in uh precious metals before in my life
and
uh i think especially with all the
craziness that we're all seeing not a
not a terrible idea to do so also they
have this great new product
it's a 24 karat gold nine millimeter
bullet
obviously don't shoot it unless you're
aiming at a werewolf but really really
cool product
visit getacregirl.com michael and start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient at get underscore acre
that is getacreal.com michael and thank
you get acre gold for supporting the
show
acre gold has a great new way to invest
in physical gold go check out acre gold
today chris harrison of bachelor fame
defends the contestant for attending a
party that was politically incorrect
years prior
fine i actually sort of give him credit
for saying we need a culture of grace we
don't
we shouldn't just be jumping on top of
one another and trying to destroy each
other's livelihoods all the time in bad
faith
but then he made a fatal error and i
don't think anybody's going to be
defending him anymore
he apologized for
encouraging grace and for defending the
girl
why would you defend rachel kirknell i
am an imperfect man
i made a mistake and i own that
i believe that mistake doesn't reflect
who i
am or what i stand for
i am committed to
chris harrison of bachelor fame
defends the contestant for attending a
party that was politically incorrect
years prior fine i actually sort of give
him credit for saying we need a culture
of grace we don't
we shouldn't just be jumping on top of
one another and trying to destroy each
other's livelihoods all the time in bad
faith
but then he made a fatal error and i
don't think anybody's going to be
defending him
anymore he apologized
for encouraging grace and for defending
the girl why would you defend rachel
kirknell
i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that i believe
that mistake doesn't reflect who i am
or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise so this
is pitiful to watch a grown man do this
but it's it's also
despicable because he was making a
principled stand to say no i'm going to
defend
this girl who was a contestant against
the mob for doing something that should
not
cause her to have her life ruined that
was a principled stand now she's ju
and now he's throwing that all under the
bus right he's throwing the girl under
the bus and he's also saying
i'm throwing my past self under the bus
for even considering defending her he's
totally undermining the principle to me
i see no reason
to defend this guy anymore i'm sure the
reason he did it is because he's weak
and that's very sad
but what can you do i was debating this
issue with megyn kelly last week i was
on megan kelly's podcast
which you can download it's out now and
we were debating this apology
she was the one who called this guy to
my attention because i'd i'd never
i couldn't have picked him out of a
lineup i hadn't you know you'd be
shocked to hear i don't i don't watch
the bachelor all the time
and negan said look i get it he's got a
good gig
all these guys were talking about the
mumford and sons musician
now his name escapes me too all these
people who were constantly being
canceled and then they cave to the woke
mob
and and megan said look it's a good gig
and so
i get it this is what traditionally is
what people do and
i pointed out to her i said yes in the
past
even if you think it's kind of silly you
contravene whatever the fashionable
political
ideas are of the day you apologize
especially if you do something actually
wrong you apologize and then people
forgive you and that's that
but that's not what's happening right
now the choice is not between
speak out against the mob stand up for
grace stand up for the girl
and lose your job and
don't cave to the mob but keep your job
that's not the choice
you've already lost your job the only
question is are you going to degrade
yourself further
it reminds me of one of the last scenes
of breaking bad
way toward the end of the series spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it but it was
on what like 10 years ago so you know
you missed your window for for spoilers
the brother-in-law the cop
brother-in-law hank is lying there on
the ground
walter the the drug runner is
there and he's he's pleading with hank
he says hank please
just tell this cartel kingpin type guy
just tell him you you'll protect him you
won't
turn him in you won't go after him just
please just beg for your life
and then he'll let you live and the cop
hank has one of the most memorable lines
in tv
hank sent to me
you gotta tell me you gotta tell them
now that we can work this out
please please
what you want me to beg
you're the smartest guy i ever met
and you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're gonna do
you're the smartest guy i ever met
you're too stupid to see he made up his
mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're gonna do the mob made up
their mind
for all these people like chris harrison
the mumford and sons musician
the the mob already made up its mind the
the
end more to it the people who have
crafted political correctness already
made up their mind
the only question is are you going to
degrade
yourself roger scrutin the conservative
philosopher at this great point i just
hosted an event
also last week for the roger scrutin fat
legacy foundation
it's between jacob rees-mogg the leader
of the house of commons and
robbie george professor of princeton i
think you can find it on youtube
scrutin made this point we discussed it
during the event
society is based on confession and
forgiveness
the ability for me to say hey i did
something wrong i'm sorry
i sacrifice my pride by confessing that
and then
for the everybody else for them to be
able to say okay i forgive you and they
sacrifice their resentment
and both people are giving up something
that they cherish
our pride and our resentments but we
trust one another we move on because
we're interested in moving forward
as a people and this is all conditioned
by and and impelled by grace by this
christian
religion that undergirds our whole
civilization when you lose that
you lose that ability for
confession and forgiveness that's where
we are
now never never never give in
i wish we could live in a society where
we can we don't want to apologize for
things we're not sorry for but where we
could all say ah yeah i just i said that
a little wrong i did that a little wrong
i'm sorry please forgive me okay we
forgive you america is the land of
second chances great
but we ain't there anymore that's over
the only question is are you going to
humiliate yourself for the mob before
they
before they destroy your livelihood
speaking
of racial bias actual racial bias not
not this kind of
chris harrison stuff tom cotton just
absolutely
wrecked one of joe biden's nominees
nominee for
associate attorney general vanita gupta
vanita gupta believes in
something called implicit racial bias
that we all have implicit racial biases
she's spoken about this at length
publicly so tom cotton had a simple
question for her
he asked her if everyone's got these
racial biases
what are yours last summer nine months
ago you are in front of this committee
and senator corden said
do you believe that all americans are
racist
you you replied yes i think that we all
have implicit biases and racial biases
yes i do so miss gupta i ask you against
which races do you harbor
racial bias senator cotton i do not
the yes was to say that all of us
have implicit bias this was an exchange
also that judge garland had with senator
kennedy during his hearing
i believe that we all have implicit bias
it doesn't mean that we are harboring
any racism at all these are unconscious
assumptions and stereotypes that can get
made
uh and i remember uh that summer in the
exchange with senator cornyn that we
were discussing systemic racism and
implicit bias
and my response was to say that all of
us have implicit bias
yeah yes i know that you said all of us
have implicit advice did you it was just
that word
salad meant absolutely nothing she said
yes we all have implicit racial biases
but it doesn't doesn't mean we're racist
because they're
they're implicit and we all have them
yeah yeah i know we all have them
you i don't agree with that by the way i
i don't think that i have them
but you're saying everybody including
you
has the biases so the question is
what are your biases well to be precise
you said we all have implicit biases and
racial biases that's all every single
american you accused of implicit bias
and racial bias
so i'm asking you again against which
races do you harbor
racial bias i am quite aware that i know
that i hold stereotypes that i have to
manage i'm a product of my culture i'm a
product it's part of the human condition
and i believe that you know one of the
reasons i believe
that all of us um are able to manage
implicit bias but only if we can
acknowledge our own and
i am not above anyone else in that
matter um i think implicit bias is
something that is part of the shared
human condition
yeah yeah okay so you believe you're not
above anyone you have them right that's
not what we're asking we're not asking
do you have them you've already stated
that
we're asking which ones get specific
what do you think about black people
well it's implicit okay so what are
because you
acknowledge them they can't be totally
implicit right they've got to be
somewhat explicit that's the only way
you could be conscious enough of them
to acknowledge that you have them so
what are they what do you think about
mexicans what do you think about asians
what are you come on
let's get specific no i don't think i'm
better than okay good
i acknowledge them okay acknowledge them
right now then go on the record
then cotton ends it
so uh in the trump administration you
strongly opposed the nominations to the
federal courts of the following
uh persons patrick boumatee michael park
and ada brown a filipino-american a
korean-american
and an african-american should members
of those communities be worried that you
harbor racial bias against them since
you oppose those judge's nominations
i'm not sure i see how that connection
is being made senator the
the leadership conference for decades
has reviewed the civil rights records
of individual judicial nominees in
democratic and republican
administrations
and there were judges that we opposed
based on their
civil rights record no senator i oppose
those racial minorities because of their
record it wasn't because of their race
well how can you know that for sure when
you've just said
that everyone has implicit racial biases
youth you're what you're saying is
because when when when venita gupta says
all of us she really just means all you
people not me
so she says look you all think that
you're acting in good faith and you
think you have all this this good
decision-making apparatus and this
fact is a reason but no it's all your
implicit racism that you're not even
aware of
well okay what if i apply that logic to
you
when you voted against those racial
minorities
isn't that evident according to your own
theory isn't that evidence
that you you were racially
discriminatory well no
no because i i'm aware of of my implicit
biases okay so then the implicit biases
don't exist for you no everybody has the
implicit biases
i think we ought to be able to conclude
from vanita gupta's
meandering testimony that this this
ideology the implicit bias the stuff
that's affecting
boardrooms universities all of it is
not a coherent theory of human nature of
politics of race
it is a weapon to be wielded against
one's political opponents and the left
is
shocked that someone like tom cotton
would have finally had the idea
can you believe it took us all this long
would have had the idea
to use that same weapon against the
people
who invented it absolutely wonderful
thing to listen to when i want to listen
to great stuff
i love checking out raycon whether
you're catching up on your
favorite podcast ahem ahem
binging an audio book or powering
through your workout with a pumped up
playlist a pair of rakons in your ears
can make all the difference
no dangling wires or stems to get in
your way there
raycons come in a range of stylish
colorways always with a comfortable
in-ear fit for a more discreet look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction
and bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly also
got enough battery life for six hours of
play time
that means you can unplug for quite a
while the best part of this
raycon makes great sound available to
everyone with wireless earbuds
starting at half the price of other
premium audio brands i'm just going to
put this very bluntly
raycon superior to the competition it's
a superior product okay and you'll save
a lot of money raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you've got to do
to get it go to buy raycon calm slash
knowles and that's it
you'll get 15 off your entire rakon
order so feel free to grab a pair and a
spare that's 15
off at byracon.com knowles raycon
earbuds oh man are they great head on
over go
check out raycon so speaking of
before we get to dr fatty i do want to
get to dr fetchy but before we get to
him
we've been talking about this for a week
now this is where it gets really
exciting
because this friday march 19th is the
premiere of candace
daily wire's new talk show hosted by
conservative lightning rod
candice owens in her new show candace
shows her personal side to her guests
and her live audience
while she tackles the big political and
cultural topics of the week
with her signature blend of humor and
insight don't forget candace starts this
friday march 19th
it will be exclusive to the daily wire
meaning the actual members now we love
all of you who
listen out there and radio land and we
love people who are watching on youtube
but this is for daily wire members if
you're not a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas for 25 off
that's dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas for 25 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
this idea of implicit racial
bias and all the kind of race hustling
nonsense that we're hearing from
biden appointees and the left more
broadly
it is a a myth it's the sort of
uh myth that uh people begin their
politics with this
you know we're we're going to just agree
on these kind of stories that we're
going to tell ourselves
and that is going to uh lead us to
making further political decisions so
because we all have implicit racial
biases what's the evidence of that we
don't have any
what is the meaning of that uh we can't
find any
uh how does it even make sense if we're
consciously talking about something that
is by definition implicit doesn't make
any sense
we're just going to start there and then
the policy is going to flow
from it right and the policy all favors
this kind of crazy left-wing view
rand paul is calling this tactic out in
not not in the race arena but in the
public health arena
rand paul is pointing out that dr fauci
is not presenting the science so much as
he's presenting
noble lies a noble lie is
is a concept that has been a part of our
politics for a long time
goes back to ancient greece fauci is
making himself a sort of philosopher
king
imposing noble lies on us for our own
good
people are afraid of you know scientists
and he's
put on a pedestal but you have to
remember that his lies are
noble lies laura he's not telling you
this because he's a mean man
he's telling you lies because he feels
sorry for you because you don't
understand and americans aren't smart
enough to make informed decision
so he fashions himself some sort of
greek philosopher
he tells you these noble lies so at
first he told you that
all the masks don't work but he told you
that because he wanted to protect the
n95 masks which actually in a hell
setting do work
but then later on he said all masks do
work but that's also a lie also because
really only the n95 masks work
but it's a compilation of lies but
they're all done to protect you because
he doesn't think you're smart enough
to make any of these decisions on your
own absolutely right dr fauci admitted
this himself when he had to answer for
his
early admonition telling everybody that
we should not wear masks it's crazy to
wear mask stoneware masks when he had to
answer for that after he changed his
mind he said well
the fear at that time was that we
weren't going to have enough masks for
the healthcare workers
and i felt it was more important to save
them to the health for the healthcare
workers so i told everybody else not to
wear masks and that they shouldn't wear
masks and it wouldn't help them
but i don't really believe that i
believe it will help them
so now you should disregard what i
previously said
and believe my new guidance which
contradicts what i'd previously said
he was making a political statement
there right he was saying this group of
people should get the masks but not this
group of people
this is the way that he convinced people
to do this is through this sort of a
noble
lie which goes back to plato's republic
the idea that there are some
lies that you tell the people that are
actually salutary they're actually for
their benefit
and this this concept has been debated
for a long time well here's the modern
incarnation of the modern incarnation
is dr fauci and the media are promoting
these
noble lies fauci was just doing
a an interview on meet the press with
chuck todd
and chuck todd asked what we would do in
the next pandemic
which he further asserted would be
caused by climate change
you know when you think about sadly
having to prepare for this again
right and i know there's a lot of folks
who who think that
you know due to climate change and due
to the
globalization in general it's inevitable
we're going to deal with more and more
viruses like this um the biggest lesson
you're
you're going to take away to prepare for
the next one
climate change is going to give us
more viruses
not the bat market in wuhan not the
wuhan institute of virology
that those sorts of things there's no
chance
that anything like that is responsible
for the virus it's because of
climate change which could either be
global cooling which we were warned
about by the experts in the 70s
or it could be global warming or once
the warming kind of stopped for a while
it could be
just the climate change that's what
causes it
climate change like this
public health tyranny that we're living
under now is this kind of a catch-all
regardless of the scientific reasoning
the scientific reasoning always seems to
change
but the effect of it is always the same
with global cooling they said the earth
is going to
head into a new ice age and therefore we
need to
stop having as many babies use
contraception
expand abortion give the government much
more control over our lives seed
political rights not just to our
national governments
but to international governments as well
then the scientific argument completely
reversed itself
within the following two decades and
what happened the political consequences
exactly the same then when the warming
kind of stopped for a little bit
what happened the scientific reasoning
changed but the political consequence is
exactly the same
i've often referred to the lockdowns
over covid19
as the green new deal through the back
door because
it gave the technocratic left everything
they wanted all the kind of stuff that
they wanted
in their environmental proposals
policies reminiscent of those called for
in the green new deal massive
redistribution of wealth
a massive surrendering of constitutional
rights a
an expansion of international government
it just got that through the back door
right it was a different okay it's yeah
forget it it's global warming or it's
the wuhan virus or yeah whatever
just do what we say that you should do
the problem here is if you have
a public health apparatus a political
apparatus more broadly
that is operating on these sorts of
noble lies that that believes that it
can with impunity
lie to you tell you things that it knows
or not true
because it feels that it's in your best
interest
then one we've totally undermined
constitutional government
but two we have no more basis
for our uh trust in these institutions
because they've already told us that
they're misleading us so we can't even
if we wanted to believe them we can't
really do that anymore speaking of which
by the way
dr fauci christmas came early he's
giving us a little present
we can now reduce social distancing from
six feet to three feet
because of you know the science or
whatever
in terms of cdc guidance as you know
the guidance for social distancing for
how far people should be
there's a there's a discrepancy some
places some health organizations say
three feet or a meter
is enough but here in the united states
we say six feet
there's this new study from researchers
in massachusetts just out this week
it found no significant difference in
coronavirus spreading in schools
where there were six feet of distancing
versus three feet of distancing
but that six foot requirement that's one
of the main hurdles to
reopening schools right does this study
suggest to you that
three feet is good enough
it does indeed and that's exactly the
point i'm making
chuck what the cdc wants to do is they
want to accumulate
data and when the data shows that there
is an ability to be
three feet they will act accordingly
absolutely dr
jake that is a very profound scientific
observation now you only require
three feet to slow the spread
until next week when i just pick another
number out of a hat
and talk about all the data that show
that how does anybody fall for this
you get these two politicians you jake
tapper who's a politician working in
journalism
but he's you know he's been a political
animal his whole life he's worked for
politicians
and you get dr fauci who just is a
politician right he's
his check is signed by the government
he's served under multiple presidents
he's got longer political staying power
than just about anybody in public life
and these two guys are espousing their
political points of view
and grabbing a lot of political power
but because they put glasses on
and they try to sound like they're nerds
or something
now we're supposed to pretend this is
not political at all this is all
just the science what was the argument
for the social distancing an orwellian
term that i never use earnestly
the argument for the social distancing
this this
contradiction in terms is that
you might have a droplet that leaves
your mouth and you know it lands on
somebody and he's got the mask so
hopefully that'll protect it but still
you know it could land on him
and so therefore we need to stand a
little further apart
now you can stand a little closer
are people spitting less forcefully now
is that the idea that our
plosive sort of sounds that we make out
of our mouth are a little less plosive
or something what on earth could the
argument be
that now into this a year into the
pandemic
once people in most
demographic groups are not really
getting that sick from it and
once people are now getting the vaccine
now it's three feet for
for what there's no this is obviously
partaking of the same political strategy
that fauci has been employing
since the very beginning in which he's
even admitted
people beginning i think to wake up a
little bit to this obviously some people
on the right have been woke to this from
the top
but even some people on the left or
waking up to the
oligarchic tendencies
technocratic oligarchic tendencies this
tendency to take
power for a handful of elites on the
left sarah silverman
a left-wing comedienne certainly
not a conservative this lady she was
just complaining about about the
democratic party
and how elitist it's all become
it's the absolutist
ness of the party i am in
that is such a turn off to me
it's so [ __ ] elitist you know for
something called progressive
it allows for zero progress
it's all or nothing no steps toward
all or nothing so
i sympathize with her her exasperation i
guess i empathize with it too
but i don't think she's right i don't
think what she's saying is exactly i
don't think it's all or nothing i think
the way the left has
won in this country on at least on the
cultural matters
is through incremental change this is
actually the topic of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which you can pre-order now until
it's canceled and then you can't
pre-order it
which is that for at least 60-80 years
the left was gaining ground engaging in
what
a brilliant leftist theorist called a
war of position where you infiltrate the
institutions
you gain power and then slowly slowly
gradually gradually
you begin to exercise that power and
then when you've got enough leverage you
can
suddenly spring a lot of social changes
on people
this to attain what he called the
cultural hegemony
which was the big impediment to leftist
radicals upending society
i want to focus though on this elitism
thing because
creating a new elitism is the point of
progressivism she's saying it like it's
a contradiction that's so weird we're
supposed to be progressives but we're
elitist
the whole point of progressivism you can
read this in woodrow wilson's essay what
is progress
he's our first left-wing progressive
president
he said the constitutional order was
under the laws of isaac newton
fixed laws permanent laws to the
universe permanent human nature
but now we're living under the world of
darwin where everything is mutable and
changeable and evolving
and in that world the constitution is
outdated so what we need to do
is instead of being governed by the
people according to the constitution
we need a group of intellectual
progressive elites
to make all of our decisions for us and
we're going to outsource this to
something called the administrative
state
and then we're going to you know still
have politics kind of we're going to
debate
pointless stuff but really the decisions
are going to be made by experts
such as dr fauci sarah silverman goes on
again righteousness porn
and i've been thinking about this a lot
just in general
i i just i don't know that i want to be
associated with any party
i really i think i don't want to be
associated with
any party anymore it just
it comes with too much baggage
every party it comes with so much
[ __ ] baggage that no
ideas can be taken at face value
and without ideas what are we
without a common truth how can we talk
about it
you know dante actually makes this point
in the divine comedy when he's talking
to his ancestor kacha guida
talks about becoming a party of one
because the parties are always going to
disappoint you because they're these
institutions so
there's something profound in what she's
saying and i'm glad she wants to break
away from her own party
but the thing is she's accusing
progressives of falling into this trap
of dithering because everything's got to
be perfect and it's all or nothing and
so they don't get anything done
she's falling into this same dithering
trap because in politics if you want to
do anything
you need to operate in tandem with other
people
and the way that we do that is we form
associations that we call political
parties
and that's how you build a consensus and
get things accomplished
you need political parties to do stuff
in government such as ours
even further though even further this
whole
both parties are terrible thing i'm so
i'm too good for all these parties
to me this whole shtick is so arrogant
and presumptuous
statistically 100 of voters fall
into one of the two major political
parties you're talking now about 150
million people
in this last election depending on the
numbers you're looking at it could be
160 million people fall into these two
parties those are just the voters
even more than that identify with the
parties
if all those people are in one of the
two parties and you're not
is it possible that you're the one with
the problem
it can't possibly be you right it's
gotta be 150 million people totally
wrong
me totally right generally speaking the
reason people fall into these parties
the reason the parties form
is because there's some coherence to the
ideas the idea that i would protect
life and protect my property the idea
that i would you know protect life
through social policy and protect my
property through economic policy
those things go together they come from
a coherent
uh base that forms a political vision
that then expresses itself in various
policies
same thing on the left the idea that you
would
upend various social policies and upend
the economic institutions of government
end up end our foreign policy
sure it comes from the same broad
political vision
and maybe you have a problem with that
but i think it's so arrogant to say and
now whatever heterodox views i hold
that's my real opinion
no maybe you're just beginning to
question your old political vision
but you haven't taken the time and the
effort to
follow your new curiosities to their
logical conclusion
which might not leave you alone outside
the political system it just might
flip you over to the other side
some guys are able to evade political
categorization
guys like bill maher now bill maher he's
a left-winger he's a democrat
but more than most left-wingers and
democrats he sort of
contradicts his own group every now and
again and it's won some respect
from right wingers usually i disagree
with bill maher but occasionally i agree
with him and he's made this point
getting back all the way to what we were
talking about at the top with that
military guy prattling on about how
women or
pregnant women are just as lethal as men
he says americans are
becoming a silly people
and finally new rule you're not going to
win the battle for the 21st century if
you are
a silly people and americans are a silly
people
that's the classic phrase from lawrence
of arabia when lawrence tells his
bedouin allies that as long as they stay
a bunch of squabbling tribes
they will remain a silly people well
we're the silly people now
do you know who doesn't care that
there's a stereotype of a chinese man in
a dr
seuss book china all 1.4 billion of them
could give a crouching tiger flying
because they're not a silly people if
anything they are as serious as a prison
fight
look we all know china does bad stuff
they break promises about hong kong
autonomy they put uyghurs in camps and
punish dissent and we don't want to be
that but
it's got to be something between
authoritarian government that tells
everyone what to do
and a representative government that
can't do anything at
all thank you bill he's ninety percent
right here ten percent he's confused but
ninety percent right
thank you first of all this
dichotomy he's making between
authoritarian government
and free representative government i
think it's kind of a false dichotomy
because america has always been a
representative government i think we're
less representative now
than we used to be during the founding
era now we have government
largely by administrative fiat not by
the will of the people
as we as we vote but
do you think that america in 2021 is
more or less authoritarian than we were
in 1790. i in
i think a lot of people would say that
we are
less authoritarian right we can
say more things we have less strict
social mores just just on the
example of free speech
we can now burn the american flag
while downloading high-speed porn
probably in public in some places
while smoking a fat blunt and
nobody will say boo about it
all of those various activities are in
various ways protected by the law
you couldn't have done that in 1790 so
then you'd say okay well that's
it was more authoritarian way back then
but in some ways it's much more
authoritarian now
because we can vote and we can vote and
we can vote
and if our votes if our expressed will
either
that of the people or of our
representatives contradicts
the politically correct bureaucratically
entrenched orthodoxy it's not going to
go anywhere
that's why these things often die in the
courts that's why
that's why president trump you elect
president trump but he can't even
control the executive branch in many
ways because the bureaucracy
functions on its own according to
progressivism as it was established 100
years ago
that is some
useless i think sort of a dichotomy the
question is do we have purpose do we not
have purpose
in the 1790s i think we had purpose as a
country i think we had a shared
sense of national identity and i think
we understood
our purpose as a country our ideals how
we were going to put them into practice
now i don't think we do this is a sign
of decadent cultures
and we i think have certainly fallen
into decadence decadent
and decay describe the same sort of
things
so what we do is we turn inward this is
expressed in declining birth rates we're
not really as focused on the next
generation
this is expressed in exploding debt
we're not focused on the next generation
right we're just focused on spending
spending spending
and ourselves uh having a luxurious sort
of
lifestyle we're focused on our own
appetites so much of our national debate
revolves around which of our sexual
desires we're allowed to pursue
today and and which new desires we'll be
able to pursue
tomorrow we're not talking about broader
things we're not talking about virtue
all that much we're not talking about
our international our geopolitical ends
we're not talking about higher ideals
silly silly stuff coca-cola just
announced great example of this in
corporate america
they announced they're only going to
hire law firms with a
a certain quota of black lawyers they
want
only law firms that that commit to
providing 15 percent of
billed time from black attorneys
this is this is a higher percentage than
the percentage of black people in
america
talk about institutional racism
they're saying we need a higher
percentage of black lawyers
black lawyers time than we have black
people in america
a serious corporation in a serious
country
would say that our criteria for
our law firms involve
having the best lawyers that's the only
criterion that matters we want the
absolute best lawyers to get us the best
deals and to get us the the best cases
made in courts
and so that's what we're going to do but
now that's not what it's about for the
military in a serious country the only
criterion is
lethality force the per what is the
purpose of the military if you had asked
people 10 years ago they would have said
the purpose of the military is to kill
our enemies
that's it to kill our enemies and
thereby
to make a credible show of force that
means that hopefully the military won't
need to be used all that much
but now the purpose of the military is
to
what to make certain people feel good
about themselves
if we're really at this point where it
is
a political crime where we'll be
attacked actually in public by the
military if we say that
maybe pregnant women shouldn't be
shooting you know ar-15s down the range
maybe that's like not the smartest thing
to do
maybe that doesn't help military
preparedness or the women
if we're now at that point then we've
had some mission drift somewhere haven't
we
now the purpose of the military is to
make everyone feel really good about
themselves based on their sexual
impulses their desires their identity
their
sex itself natural sex the purpose of
the
of the law firm is to make people like
feel good about themselves or some sort
of
social experiment that is
unserious stuff and a brief study of
history
shows that decadent cultures
don't get to last that long in their
present form
because decadent cultures are not strong
i don't think this is a problem that
pervades all the people
all the enlisted guys all the officers
in the military i don't think that the
corruption at the fbi
involves all of the officers or the
corruption and
but there are people in power who have
attained power in all of these
institutions
including the military who are
utterly subverting the purpose and
mission not only of those institutions
but then collectively
of society might be time for us to
finally win
and wield some political power i'm
michael noel's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show